- [Mark] All right, Ian.
Ian, where'd you grew up,
where are you from originally?
- [Ian] Well, originally from Kentucky,
but Kentucky, Germany, back and forth.
- [Mark] Oh really?
And tell me about your childhood.
You have both your parents
growing up as a kid?
- Yeah. Unfortunately.
- [Mark] How, how was your childhood?
- It was brutal.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- I was beaten every single day.
My father tried to drown me several times
as such an electrical fence
to make sure it was working
just anything and everything
he could come up with.
He was verbal.
He was
mean, he was those horrible names
he wouldn't smear stuff all
at my poop, all over my face.
And he was just, he was
just a horrible person.
- [Mark] And you had a mom that was
- Yeah, they did nothing about it
and thought that it was
perfectly acceptable to
allow him to do that to me.
- [Mark] Wow.
You had siblings?
- Hm mm.
- [Mark] And they got the same treatment?
- No, they helped.
They would set me up and then go running
and crying and they'd get me in trouble.
- [Mark] Well, why do you
think you got singled out?
- Let's see, it was the red hair,
because he could tell I
was gay right off the bat,
just many different things.
And I found out later that he was
he had homosexual tendencies himself
and I think it was himself, that he saw
in me that he feared the most.
- [Mark] So you've tell him what age?
- 17. I put a 12 gauge,
shotgun up his nose
and told him if he had
ever touched me again
I would blow his brains out.
And I meant it.
I took his truck and left.
- [Mark] So it was mostly like
physical and verbal abuse?
- Physical, verbal, emotional, everything.
- [Mark] Yeah, but not sexual?
- He tried,
but I wasn't going for it.
- [Mark] And where'd you go after that?
- I went to the army.
- [Mark] Oh is that right?
And you've spend how many years there?
- In the army?
Well,
seven yeah, seven.
I tried to shoot him once
he too always took behind me
and would walk right in front of me.
And I was such a lousy shot.
I clipped his ear.
So yeah, I went to the army to get away
from him and to learn how to shoot.
And basically, I didn't know
how to, because you know
it was a farm, I didn't
know how to make a living.
I didn't know how to pay rent.
I didn't know anything about anything.
I needed some, I needed some sort
of coverage and I thought
army would be great
because it would also teach me to,
be able to fight back.
- [Mark] Yeah,
and after the army,
you came back to where?
- After the army I went to live
with my grandmother in Germany.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right.
because I was stationed
in Germany and I met her.
Yeah. She, as long as my
mother was married to my father
she refused to have anything
to do with the family.
- [Mark] And eventually you
made it out to San Francisco.
- Yeah.
It was a Securities route.
Let's see my daughter and
I were living in Atlanta.
And I usually, I used to
spend maybe five years
at a city and then decided,
okay, it's time to move.
And we moved from
Atlanta to San Francisco,
I've been here for almost 25 years.
I just, everything
about it just said, okay
this is your city.
When I first got here
there was a woman standing
outside the dollar store
with a big container of baby powder
jumping around her head and
dancing around like a ballerina.
I was like, Oh, this is perfect.
This is the city for me.
And I noticed that everyone
was just a little odd
and a little weird, but individual way.
And that's really what I loved
about city is that so many
individuals, it wasn't mass.
You know, everyone had to be together
and had to look the same and had to go
to the same church and thought
processes had to be similar
and everything like that.
You were allowed to be an individual here.
That's really what
attracted me to the city.
- [Mark] That's great,
and your happy here?
- For the most part,
sex has been horrible.
I haven't had sex
in almost two years because
guys here really suck.
But other than that, then we
have set a lot of assholes,
a lot of people that just go
out of their way to, you
know, abuse those people.
I never got shy about it.
They're not a, there's no
shame in the game there.
They're like, yeah, I'll
rob you in a heartbeat.
And you know, it's like
they're inner asshole,
met the hour asshole
and decided an asshole sandwich,
it's exactly who they were going to be.
- [Mark] So you have, you have a daughter?
- She's in college.
- [Mark] And so you were married once or
- No, no, no.
Her mother wanted my sperm
and then decided she
wasn't mother material
dropped her off at my door step.
- [Mark] So you raised your daughter?
- Hm mm.
- [Mark] And what do you do for a living?
- I'm an artist.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff?
- Every piece that I create
is completely different
from the previous one.
So, I mean, I mean,
there is nothing similar
in my pieces at all, because
I like, I like it to be fresh.
I like to be different.
I like it.
Everything about to not say, okay,
well this looks like his work.
So it just depends on my mood.
And it depends on where the piece takes me
while I'm creating it and working on it.
Because sometimes the piece
decides what it wants to be
before I even know.
- [Mark] So it can be anything.
- It can be anything.
Yeah. Sometimes I'll divide up a piece of,
canvas and have like four
panels doing different things.
Or sometimes, I'll start making
like these little symbols and stuff
over here and maybe some
squiggles and stuff over here.
And at some point, it all
just meshes into something.
- [Mark] So you're, you're not unfamiliar
with the Tenderloin
- Not at all
- [Mark] And where we are now?
And that's, because you
have a past with drugs?
- I have a past with
drugs, a future with drugs
I tried the clean and sober cult stuff.
It didn't work for me.
I got fat.
People were ugly, sober,
and quite honestly
the whole thing just turned me off.
- [Mark] So what is your drug today?
- Speed.
- [Mark] Crystal meth.
Yeah. That's a common drug now.
- It is.
- You know, I went from
one job to the next
to the next crack out here
really sucks.
The rock, the cocaine here,
the quality is really bad.
You get a smidgen and
your always running around
trying to get more and more and more.
I refuse to be a hamster
on a wheel I'm way too lazy.
I don't like working as
a four-letter word to me.
So why would I work to try to get my job?
And the thing is you work hard
running after stuff to sell
and getting the money for the doggie,
and then you only enjoyed
the drug for like a moment.
And then you got to
repeat the cycle again.
And you know, you just,
you get so exhausted.
You never have a place to sleep.
You never have a place to live.
You never had any friends
because you're constantly
chasing this drug.
And I decided I was trying to change up
to something different that
would mellow me out and last
longer, and speed's done it for me.
- [Mark] Yeah. And you're,
you're still functioning, as if
you're working or you're not working?
- Well, work is a four letter word.
- [Mark] But you're not
living on the streets.
- No, no, no.
I have a place, I have a
beautiful place actually.
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah.
- That I can easily afford.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- I have a car and everything.
- [Mark] What do you do it for money?
Is your art generally?
- Yeah. Great.
- [Mark] So do you have friends?
- I have a lot of friends.
Yeah.
I have really good friends.
I tend to vibe with people
who are similar to me.
We don't, I don't rob any
bank I don't cheat anybody.
I am,
I don't lie to people.
I don't believe there's
any reason to, most people
I can't stand it.
Honestly, if I don't care about you
I don't care what you say about me.
You can call me whatever
the fuck you want to.
And these are friends
that have similar mindset.
We just, we're good people.
And we decide, we're like
we're gonna remain good people.
But at the same time
we don't take any bullshit
and we help each other out.
We help other people out.
And this is becoming a connection
with them it's growing,
it's like, this thing
that is becoming larger
and larger and we're getting
more and more people,
in our group of friends,
- [Mark] That's great.
- We have to kind of conglomerate
together because you know
all the assholes and all the other shits,
coming out from all
directions, we might as well,
become a big center
piece that can get bigger
and bigger and bigger, more stronger.
- [Mark] So you mentioned the
car that you're like a misfit?
- Not so much anymore.
No. Well, yeah, people still, you know
it's like the other day
these two guys were whispering
and laughing and pointing.
I'm like, well, at first
I'm spotting a fag,
Congratulations. You've
spotted one all by yourself.
- [Mark] I mean, do you see
that the group of friends
that you have kind of would
fit in the same category?
- It is the same guy category as I do.
And the thing is where
we're brutally honest with each other
and make each other crack each
other up because, you know
I am who I am and they don't care.
You know, I have my straight friend Otto
who's like completely opposite.
He's got tattoos all over the place.
He looks like a biker dude,
and you know, he's completely serious.
And he's one of my best friends and,
he's and I said, Oh yeah,
that, that's being a smart.
I was being a big and smart ass back.
And he's like, Oh no, not you.
And we just know each other well enough
that we all clicked as friends.
You know, I used to perv on him and,
he used to check his fly
every time he saw me coming, I'm like, Oh
you'd have to check
your flight every time.
I'm not always looking at your crotch.
Sometimes I'm looking at your ass.
- [Mark] With your past
with the drugs and Tenderloin and all that
what kind of crazy stories
did you have to share?
- So many
- The six year old boy, walking
through the Tenderloins
three o'clock in the morning
his little six year old
boy says, is you fag?
I said, well, most days, yeah.
Will you come with me?
So I followed him to his SRO.
He has me wait in lobby.
He goes upstairs, get his little brother.
His little brother comes out.
And he turns, it turns to his brother.
He says, I brought you fag.
I was pimped out by a six-year-old.
His brother hit him in the arm.
He said, I'm not gay,
but I was just like, wow.
Only in the Tenderloin in San Francisco
would you find this shit?
Yeah. There also a
number of people that get
on our building that
really weren't supposed to
have any guests, but there
are ways in the building.
And it seems like the
people that aren't living
in a building, but actually are as growing
in numbers and the people
that used to be living
in a building and they're kinda gone,
and we've got like half the building
out with people that
aren't actually residents
but they're living in rooms.
And it's funny to me,
we get a lot of people
with mental health issues,
which I tend to have patience
and kindness for before, the most
because I understand you can't
help mental health issues
but then we get the people
who want to come in and
just terrorize and cause problems.
And, we don't stand for that.
It's an interesting dynamic COVID
and how it has not affected anybody.
Who's using drugs.
In fact, we have this idea
that if you're abusing drugs,
then COVID, won't have
anything to do with you.
You know, we don't know
anybody who's sick, you know?
And it's, it's funny because,
every time I walk in there
like I was getting a burger
today from this food truck.
And there were like, where's your mask?
And I'm like, I don't
know, where's your ass?
I just, I hate those
masks they're too high.
I can't breathe in them.
And it just, I don't know.
I like
how it's divided people
and change people in some ways
and know it's brought people
together in other ways.
And
I've noticed that there's a
lot of humanity coming out.
A lot of kindness, a lot
of people going out of their way to,
express that there are
good people out here.
And I like that side.
I see in people.
- [Mark] So, being gay
and being in San Francisco
it's like a much more accepted thing.
You don't have any?
- Oh please, No.
- [Mark] Still here?
- No. We've got it, we've got
homophobes, left and right,
center, and I love them.
But yeah, when they call me fag, I'm like
what you think you're
giving me holiday nuance?
I know I'm a fag, what's your point?
Come up with, you need a thesaurus, honey
come up with some new adjectives, fag.
I already heard that fucking five,
every five minutes since I left the house.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life?
- Not to be ashamed of who I am
and not to be afraid to express who I am
and fuck everybody who doesn't like it.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
I'll flip my hair on, in her face,
as they mean mugging me
and they're saying shit
underneath their breath.
And I love the drive-bys.
They combine and skateboard on a bicycle
and say something nasty.
And I can't catch up with
them to beat their ass
and I'm like, Oh, you
pussy, come back here.
What did you fucking call me?
Yeah. I just drive by,
they'd go by a skateboard or bicycle.
And then they quickly
paddle off after I said
whatever the old piece was.
And I'm like, wow, they're just
not, they're not man enough
to fucking say it to
my face and stand right
and plant their legs right in front of me.
Yeah. But yeah, it's,
it is what it is.
And I accept people on their terms.
And if they don't accept me
I don't give a shit.
- [Mark] Excellent, Ian, thanks
so much for talking with me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You're very interesting.